hey everyone i'm here with my friend
eric
and we met two years ago in florida
and i was blown away by his knowledge of
the plants he's been foraging for about
a decade and
he is a plant wizard with really
seemingly infinite knowledge i know
there's things he doesn't know but it
seems like he knows
pretty much every plant that we cross
and so
i've been blessed to get to learn from
him i've been with him for the last day
in maryland and
learned so much and so i'm excited he is
going
to share some of his favorite plans to
help you get foraging and
first he's going to introduce himself a
bit my name is eric i'm a plant lover
permaculturist and an avid forager
and i'm just really grateful to be here
with you all today
and share my top 10 wild edible greens
for the mid-atlantic
and there's just such an abundance of
food in these fields and forests
so let's go see what we can find
my number one all-time favorite wild
edible green
has to be urtica dioica or
the mighty stinging nettle uh there is a
native north american species as well
urtica gracilis
and also la portia canadensis i love it
for so many reasons
it offers all kinds of amazing medicine
its flavor is incredible it can be
absolutely prolific in the wild
and it's very easy to cultivate for
those of us who are gardeners
not to mention it'll grow in full shade
underneath of
black walnuts for the permaculturists
out there
it can be made into dried green powders
or blended up into pestos
or it can also be steamed and sauteed
any kind of heat will deactivate the
stinging hairs and make it edible
but yeah definitely my number one
all-time favorite has to be
stinging nettle so number two
on my list of wild edible greens has got
to be
chickweed this is another great friend
to really connect with and bring into
the kitchen
so this is stellaria media common name
is chickweed
and i love this one because it's pretty
easy to identify it has these
really cute little star-shaped flowers
on it
and opposite leaves it's really cool and
juicy
and the flavor is really
awesome it's one that i do like to cook
because
it's a little bit higher in the oxalic
acid department
but it also makes a great pesto and can
be dried into powders
so yeah i would definitely say number
two on the list is chickweed
and keep an eye out for this one in the
spring and fall it'll disappear in the
summer
so number three on my list is lamb's
quarters this is one of the
first friends that i really got tuned in
to when i was
first starting to eat something wild
every day
the latin name is cannipodium album
and it's just an absolute superstar from
the spinach family
it's one of the most nutritious plants
on earth it's also one of the highest
wild greens in oxalic acid
so this is one that i definitely like to
cook it up i like to steam it
boil it pan fry it
anything to help cook out and denature
those oxalates but after that it's an
absolutely
flavor packed incredible edible this is
one that should be
in all the four star restaurants and it
should definitely be on everyone's plate
so can a podium album lamb's quarters
number three number four on my list is
definitely dandelion taraxicum officiale
this is one that most everybody's
probably already familiar with
it is an absolute incredible edible
the leaves are great in salad but they
can also be boiled to remove some of the
bitterness if you're not into that
they are loaded with all kinds of
nutrients
tons of vitamin a and they're the second
highest source of boron of any of the
wild greens which is cool because
boron helps to detoxify the body of
fluoride so
it's definitely an important one for us
to bring into our diets
and it's also a great one for helping to
support the liver health
and helping our body to detoxify
multiple different ways
so dandelion is definitely one for
everybody to tune into
and bring home to the dinner plate
coming in at number five
is ali area petiolata the
garlic mustard so this is a biennial
plant
in the brassica kca family the mustard
family
like the first four on our list it's and
it's a european
import that is very weedy and prolific
and this one in fact uh is alleleopathic
so
it competes against other plants in the
area and for that reason i really love
encouraging people to consume these
kinds of plants
that are exotic to our region so that we
can help
native habitats to thrive a little bit
more take some of the pressure off of
the native plants in that way
this one was brought over from europe
because it's very highly nutritious
190 milligrams of vitamin c
per 100 gram serving which is very easy
to consume in a batch of pesto
and that's definitely one of my favorite
ways to bring garlic mustard into the
kitchen is in pesto form
it also makes a great cooked green
sauteed or
even steamed up or you can boil it when
it gets older to take some of the
bitterness out
so yeah definitely number five on the
list is ali area petiolata
garlic mustard so number six on our list
is basswood this is the
american basswood talia americana
and this is a native tree in the mallow
family
and i love this one because we don't get
to eat a whole lot of tree leaves and
this one is so
mild and has such a nice flavor
that it can actually be the basis for a
salad i love
greens that we can eat raw it also makes
an excellent green powder
makes it fantastic sauteed greens
steamed
any way that you prepare it basswood is
absolutely incredible
and the leaves also have this nice kind
of mucilaginous quality to it
that i think really helps to keep us
hydrated in the summertime
and also makes for a wonderful tea when
we've got a sore throat
so yeah definitely number six on the
on the list is basswood tilia americana
so for number seven on our list we have
another tree leaf and this is one that i
bet a lot of you are already familiar
with because it is
world famous for its berries and of
course we're talking about the mighty
mulberry
so in the mid-atlantic we'd be that
would be
either morris alba which is the asian
species or morris rubra which is the
native one
they both have edible leaves there is
um an introduced species uh browzanitia
papyro fera
that is a look-alike that's worth
looking into it's called the paper
mulberry it's in the same family
but not as edible and
this one it's not as some of them are
acceptable
as a salad crop but more so i think of
mulberries as being great for green
powders or
cooked greens either steamed sauteed
or otherwise kind of cooked down a
little bit
and yeah i love mulberries because
they're so easy to identify and they're
so prolific
and they have these deep roots and
they're just beautiful amazing awesome
trees
so number seven is the mighty mulberry
morris alba morris rubra coming in at
number eight on our list
is purslane porchalaca ola racia
and this is a really great cooking green
it can also be added raw to salads the
flavor is great
it is kind of high in oxalic acid so i
do prefer to cook it myself
personally but i have heard of people
adding it to smoothies it's got a little
bit of a
sliminess to it that adds a great
mucilaginous
kind of throat coating quality to it
and one of the other things that's
amazing about this plant is
it's remarkably high omega-3
fat content so this is a great source of
omega-3 fats from
a local wild uh you know plant-based
source so yeah definitely let's say
number eight
is portulaca ola racia purslane
so number nine on our list is asclepius
syriaca
this is a native perennial that grows in
open fields
all throughout the country this one is
absolutely
incredibly delicious it's important to
boil this one twice because
it does have cardiac glycosides known as
cardinalites in it that are pretty toxic
so i like to boil it in two changes of
water
another thing to be aware of with this
plant is that it looks
very similar to another native that is
poisonous and that's dog bane
so this is the dog bane right here and
you can see that they obviously grow
in the exact same habitat and
so superficially it can be difficult to
tell the two apart but
when you get into the core of it you can
see
the inside of the milkweed is hollow
where the inside of the dog bane is
solid
and so that's a very key distinguishing
feature
that makes it easy to tell the two apart
sclepius syriaca number nine
coming in at number 10 on our list is
the mighty bidens
beggar's ticks spanish needles and with
this one we'll go ahead and say
the entire genus as far as i know every
species is edible
some are definitely better than others
i've noticed
this one in particular is biden's
frondosa
and this one is a great weedy
summer superstar it's in the aster
family
and has a little bit of kind of bitter
sappiness
to it so i do prefer to either boil or
steam it before using it for pesto
but an absolutely incredible cooking
green loaded with nutrition
and also has a medicinal component to it
as well
being very popular as a
gentle but effective antibiotic
so yeah and the common names beggars
ticks and spanish needles are a
reference to the seed
and so that makes these very easy to
identify
and you'll see them all over the place
once you start looking for them
number 10 guidance so thanks so much for
taking the time to get to know my top 10
wild
edibles for the mid-atlantic and wanted
to give a special shout out
to definitely rob greenfield and
your team thank you so much definitely
want to give
a lot of love to the folks at
metacreative for helping me with all
this filming and
putting together all the shots and
scenes and
just making this whole process so much
more
approachable for me thank you for your
help and patience
and definitely wanted to uh
give thanks to the reed center in
middletown maryland
chesapeake's bounty in st leonard
maryland and
plant path nursery in knoxville maryland
or hosting some of these video segments
and uh yeah
so thanks so much peace i hope that you
got a lot out of this video and can now
implement these things into your life
eric is a
plant educator an earth lover and a
permaculturist with so much
knowledge to share with us check the
links in this description
to follow him and make sure to subscribe
to this channel where there are many
more inspirational and educational
videos to come
i love you all very much and see you
again real soon